PROFESSOR: So my comments.
First one-- if the psi n of
t can be chosen to be real,
the geometric face vanishes.
So why is that?
The geometric face is,
remember, the integral
of this new factor, which was
i psi n of t psi n of t dot.
You had to integrate that thing
to get the geometric face.
We explained that this
quantity in general is--
well, in general, it's always
imaginary, this quantity.
And then with an i,
this is a real quantity
which we've been using.
But if this is
imaginary-- look at this.
This is imaginary.
How can it be imaginary
if psi is real?
It can't be.
If psi is real, imagine
doing that integral.
You can kind of imagine.
So it has to be
0 if psi is real.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Why did we say
that was imaginary?
PROFESSOR: We proved
this was imaginary.
We did calculate the derivative
with respect to time of psi
with psi, and we proved
that this was imaginary.
And now I'm saying if this was
imaginary but if psi is real,
the only possibility
is that this is 0.
But you can prove, in fact,
that this is 0, if this is real.
I can do it in a second.
It's i integral psi n of
p-- because it's real--
d dt of psi n of t.
Output an x here,
and this is dx.
That's what it is
if psi is real.
Otherwise there
would be a star here.
But if it's real,
there's no star.
But this is just
the integral of 1/2
of d dt of psi of
x and t squared dx.
The d dt is that.
And then the d dt goes
out of the integral--
so this is i over 2
d dt of the integral
of psi squared of x and t dx.
But that integral is 1,
so the derivative is 0.
So there's no geometric face.
So if you have real
instantaneous eigenstates,
don't even think
of Berry's phase.
There's another case where
you don't get a Berry's phase.
So when I'm speaking of
Berry's phase at this moment,
I mean the Berry's phase from
a closed pathing configuration
space.
So if the configuration
space is one-dimensional,
the Berry phase vanishes.
Barry's phase vanishes for
1v configuration space.
Why is that?
Well, what do we have to do?
The Berry's phase will be the
integral over the closed path
in the configuration
space psi of r d, d r--
because there's
just one side of r--
d r.
You have to
integrate that thing.
That is the Berry phase--
is the integral of the Berry
connection over--
this is capital R--
over the space.
But now, if this configuration
space is one-dimensional--
this is r--
a closed path is a path that
goes like this and black.
It retraces itself.
So it integrates this
quantity with increasing r,
and then it integrates
the same quantity
with decreasing r,
and the two cancel,
and this phase is equal to 0.
So you cannot get a Berry's
phase if you have one
dimension.
You cannot get the Berry's phase
if you have real instantaneous
eigenstates.
But you can get a Berry's
phase in two dimensions,
in three dimensions, and
there are several examples.
I will mention one
example, and and then
leave Barry's phase
for some exercises.
So in 3D, for example--
3D's nice.
A 3D configuration space
is the perfect place
to confuse yourself,
because you have
three dimensions
of configuration
and three dimensions of space.
So nice interplay between them--
r1, r2, r3.
And then you have an
integral-- the Berry's phase
is an integral-- over
a closed path here.
So let's call gamma and
let's call this surface, s,
whose boundary is gamma.
So what is the Berry phase?
The Berry phase is the
integral over gamma
of the Berry connection d r.
But what is that?
That is, by Stokes'
theorem, the integral
over the surface of
the curl of the Berry
connection times the area.
And so the area on that surface.
Stokes' theorem--
remember in E&M?
So here was a vector potential
gives you a magnetic field--
so the integral
of a along a loop
was equal to the flux
of the magnetic field
through the surface.
And now the berry
phase along the loop
is equal to the
integral of the--
we should call it
Berry magnetic field?
No.
When people think berries--
curvature.
As in the sense that the
magnetic field is the curvature
of that connection.
So this is called the
Berry's curvature,
but you think about
magnetic field--
Berry's curvature.
So the Berry's
curvature-- people
go with d is the curl sub r of
the Berry connection a of r.
It's the magnetic field,
so it's the integral
of d over that surface.
So they're nice analogies.
So one example you
will do in recitation--
I hope-- you have
Max over there--
is the classic example of
a spin in a magnetic field.
So I will just say a couple
of words as an introduction,
but it's a very
nice computation.
It's a great exercise
to figure out
if you understand
all these things.
It's done in [INAUDIBLE]
explicitly in some ways,
and it's a great
thing to practice.
So if you want the
little challenge--
I know you're busy with
papers and other things.
but the idea is that you
have a magnetic field--
the cogs of a
magnetic field, B0n--
along some direction n, and
you have a spin 1/2 particle
pointing in that direction n.
But then you start
letting it vary in time--
that unit vector.
So this unit vector varies
in time and traces a path.
And if it's idiomatic
process, the spin
will remain in the instantaneous
energy eigenstate, which
is spin up in this
direction, and it will track
the magnetic field, basically.
There will be some small
probability it flips,
but it's small.
And if this is an
idiomatic process,
that error can be small.
So as you move around here,
there will be a geometric face,
and the geometric
face is quite nice.
So for the spin up state--
m+ state-- if it
follows this thing,
the geometric phase for the spin
up state in this closed path
in configuration space--
this is the configuration
space of the magnetic field--
will just be given by minus 1/2.
This comes from spin
1/2 times an invariant
of this loop, which is the
solid angle traced by this loop.
So the geometric phase that's
acquired by this motion
is proportional just to the
solid angle of this loop.
It's a very nice result. Shows
how geometric everything is.